Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show.
I'm going to keep my intro spiel as short
as possible because my guest today is someone
I want to ask many, many questions.
Danny Meyer, you can find them on Twitter
@dhmeyer, M-E-Y-E-R, is the founder and chairman
of Union Square Hospitality Group, USHG, which
comprises some of New York's most beloved
and acclaimed restaurants, including Gramercy
Tavern, the modern Maialino, and more.
I have been to most of them.
As a strong island native, I have made the
track several times.
Danny and USHG also founded Shake Shack, which
you may have heard of, the modern day roadside
burger restaurant, which became a public company
in 2015.
Danny is the author of the New York Times
Bestseller, Setting the Table, which articulates
a set of signature business and life principles
that translate to a wide range of industries.
We'll be digging into that.
He's the recipient of the 2017 Julia Child
Award and was named by Time Magazine as one
of 2015's 100 most influential people.
Danny and USHG's Restaurants and individuals
together have won an unprecedented 28 James
Beard Awards, think of those as the Oscars
of food, including outstanding restaurateur
in 2005.
Danny, so nice to finally connect live.
Danny Meyer: I know, it's about time.
It's great to see you and to be with you,
Tim.
Tim Ferriss: I have so many pages in front
of me and so many questions.
It's really just been a challenge, an embarrassment
of riches in terms of where to start, but
I thought I would start with Maialino, so
little pig, little piglet.
What is the backstory on the name?
Danny Meyer: Back in, I think I was about
20 years old, I got to work for my dad, who
was in the travel business, and he was selling
these group tours to airline employees and
their families.
It was this crazy idea he had, that he had
this niche market, and he was going to aggregate
all of the kind of benefits and discounts
that you would get as an airline employee
and package them all together to create these
tours.
So by the time my brother, sister, and I each
turned 20, we were each invited by my dad
to go work as a tour guide in the city of
our choice, and my sister had picked Denmark
or Copenhagen, I picked Rome, my brother would
later pick Paris.
So I'm in Rome, and this was one of the most
pivotal parts of my entire life experience
that would probably direct where I ended up
in my career.
So I was the guy that would wake up every
single morning early, go pick up these cranky
tourists.
They were pilots, flight attendants, baggage
handlers, because keep in mind, they were
all airline employees.
I'd pick them up at the Rome airport, collect
all their luggage, get them on the tour bus.
I'd get on the microphone as a 20-year-old,
tell them all about what the next three days
were going to be like.
Here's how you've got to hold your purse so
you don't get it stolen by someone on a motorcycle.
Here's what you should or should, blah, blah,
blah.
So anyway, I was supposed to be taking these
tours to all the typical places like the cameo
factories and the Vatican Museum, all the
stuff that was on their itinerary, but instead
I was looking at this as an opportunity to
get an education in food.
So I kept going to these trattorias.
I found three different trattorias that would
actually pay me a 1,000 lira per head of every
guest I brought in.
So I'd go get free food at these really good
restaurants, and I'd end up with 25,000 lira
in my pocket afterwards.
Well, so one of the restaurants, which was
called La Taverna da Giovanni, started calling
me Meyerino, Little Meyer, because they knew
it was my dad's company.
I thought that was kind of cute.
And somehow over the course of that summer,
without my inexperienced ear really picking
it up, Meyerino, Little Meyer, had somehow
changed to Maialino, which means little pig.
The reason they did that, and the joke was
on me, but every single time I went to this
restaurant, my favorite thing to order was
the Maialino, the roast suckling pig.
So fast forward many, many years later, on
my 50th birthday, my wife Audrey, she knows
I hate surprises, so the party was not a surprise,
but what was a surprise to me is that she
had co-created a logo for my birthday, which
was Maialino, and she had my picture as a
little kid with a pig underneath it and made
these stickers for bottles of wine that everybody
was drinking that night.
And it was such a damn good logo that when
it was time to open a new restaurant, I couldn't
come up with a better name or logo.
So we ended up naming a restaurant Maialino
after this whole experience.
You can call me Little Pig or Little Meyer,
I'll answer to either one.
Tim Ferriss: Now, in the course of doing homework
for this conversation, I spotted, and this
is true for I suppose everyone on some level,
but sliding door moments, you've had so many
different sliding door moments where your
life could have cut one way or was headed
one direction and then seemed to pull a right
or a left turn at 90 degrees.
But before I get to asking about one of those,
specifically your uncle and prepping for the
LSATs, you mentioned you hate surprises.
Why do you hate surprises, or how do you think
about surprises?
Danny Meyer: I think underneath it, I'm a
little bit of a control freak, and I realize
that there's this great expression my grandfather
taught me many times, which is "Man plans,
and God laughs."
So as much as you think that you're planning
for success or planning for the stuff that's
going to work out, the world usually has another
idea for you.
So on the other hand, look, if we're driving,
I like to be behind the wheel.
It's my wiring, so I don't mind, I never mind
not knowing where the story's going to end,
but I like to have some, at least it may be
a false sense, but I like to have some sense
that at least I had some say in the matter.
I mean, I'll be flying on an airplane, and
it's not that I need to get in the cockpit
with the pilot, but for example, I'm the absolute
world's worst sleeper on airplanes.
I've got the window open, it's almost as if
I'm afraid I'm going to miss one of the clouds
outside the window if I don't keep paying
attention.
Tim Ferriss: I think I share some similar
programming, and it brings to mind for me
this metaphor that a novelist once shared
with me, which was writing a novel is like
driving a car cross country with the headlights
on.
You can't see where you're going, but you
see enough in front of you that at least you
know you're headed in the right direction.
So coming back to what I alluded to a little
bit earlier, and I know that we're establishing,
setting the table, as it were, for people
listening who may not have a whole lot of
background, you studied political science,
if I'm getting my facts straight.
Then at one point you were preparing for the
LSAT.
So you're thinking of pursuing law education,
perhaps becoming a lawyer, and you had a conversation
with your uncle.
Could you describe that conversation?
And then I have a few follow-ups.
Danny Meyer: Sure, yeah.
I mean, with a poli sci degree, and the reason
that I did study political science is as a
child of pretty much the 1970s, middle child
of three in the middlemost state in the country,
Missouri.
Republican dad, Democratic mom.
Every night at the dinner table there was
a "discussion" about politics.
Tim Ferriss: Discussion.
Danny Meyer: It could have been Watergate,
it could have been Vietnam.
The dinner table was where our family, we
could agree on what we wanted to eat, and
that was kind of about it.
The food was the comfort.
I, as the middle child, I was the one who
wanted to make everybody feel good and bring
everybody together and keep the family together.
On the other hand, as much as my dad and I
were best pals, played a lot of sports together,
just we loved, we cooked together all the
time, it was the time I spent with my mom
hanging out watching the news every night
that I found most interesting.
So I knew I loved what we used to call current
events, I just was taken by it.
So after I graduated with my poli sci degree,
I was either going to be interested in going
into politics, because what else do you do
with that kind of degree?
Or maybe I was going to go into journalism,
because I just liked either writing about
or impacting the events of the day.
So after I spent a few years being a salesman
just to make some money selling electronic
tags to stop shoplifters of all things, I
said, "You know what?
That's not what you want to do the rest of
your life."
It's been good, you made a bunch of commissions,
and I actually invested all those commissions
in that company stock, which was a good thing.
But I said, "You've got to do something right
now."
So I did take the LSATs.
I decided a law degree instead of a journalism
degree.
First of all, I think anyone who knows me
knows I would've made the world's worst lawyer
because I don't wake up every morning saying,
"I'm looking for a fight.
I'm looking to prosecute."
It's kind of the opposite, I think hospitality
is the opposite, which is, "How do we bring
people together?"
But it was on the eve of taking my LSATs,
I had taken the Kaplan course, preparing for
it and everything, hated every minute of it.
The night before going to take this test was
a Friday night when I was out to dinner with
my aunt and uncle and my grandmother in New
York City at an Italian restaurant I still
go to called Elio's.
I was in a foul, just awful mood because first
of all, I didn't want to take the test, didn't
want to be a lawyer, and my table mates were
all having a great time eating good pasta,
drinking lots of wine, and I couldn't do it.
So at a certain point my uncle, my Uncle Richard,
turns to me and he says, "What the hell is
bothering you anyway?"
And I said, "Well, I've got to take my LSAT
tomorrow morning."
And he said, "Oh, of course you do.
You want to be a lawyer, don't you?"
And I said, "Actually, no."
And basically he wanted to throw his pasta
spoon at me at that moment, and he asked me
what was, to this day, the most impactful
question of my whole life, which was one I
was not expecting.
He said, "Do you have any idea how long you're
going to be dead anyway?"
And I said, "No, I hadn't really thought about
that.
Why?"
And he said, "I don't know either, but I'll
tell you one thing.
You're going to be dead a hell of a lot longer
than you're going to be alive.
Why in the world would you do something that
you have no passion around?"
And I stopped and I said, "Because I guess
I don't know what else I could do."
And within a second, he said, "You've got
to be kidding me.
All I've heard you talk about your entire
life is food and restaurants."
And I said, "So what, am I supposed to eat
in restaurants the rest of my life?"
It was so obvious, and yet I could not see
this.
And he said, "No, you fool.
You should go open a restaurant."
It had never dawned on me that that was a
valid thing to do, because that's not what
you ever heard about in college back then.
You didn't hear about going to open a restaurant.
Now, I'm really, really glad that all these
years later being in the food business has
become a validated entrepreneurial career
choice for people within education, but it
wasn't back then, and it's still — well
here, I'll cut to the chase.
I did take the LSAT the next morning.
I had already paid for it, for God's sakes,
never applied to one school.
But what I did do is the following Monday
morning, I connected with one of my best buddies
from Trinity College who I used to go out
to eat with all the time and was a fraternity
brother, and I said, "I've got this idea.
I'm going to open a restaurant.
You be the money guy, I'll be the food guy.
What do you think?"
And he was in a bank training program at that
point, and he said, "Okay, I'll do it."
So we enrolled in the New York Restaurant
School, which was all you had to do was pay
your 150 bucks and you got in.
We took a restaurant management class, and
he promptly dropped out after two sessions
because he made the mistake of telling his
parents that he was thinking about leaving
banking to go into the restaurant business.
Bottom line is he felt so bad about leaving
me all alone that he said, "Look, our bank
has one restaurant client."
Which was a big deal because mostly banks
would run the other way if they heard the
word restaurant back then.
And he said, "I'll be glad to see if I can
get you an interview with that.
Would you like that?"
So I got the interview.
The interview pretty much consisted of the
owner sitting midway down his bar.
I'm at the front door, he waves me down the
bar, tells me to stop and stand right in front
of him.
He looks me up and down from my wallabies
up to my Brooks Brothers shirt.
He goes, "You'll do."
That was my first job interview.
I got the job and I was assistant lunch manager,
which meant nothing, which meant I was getting
250 bucks a week to answer reservation lines
and set up the reservation book for lunch
and be on the front door.
Here's the good news.
Out of that deal, I've figured out in seven
months that I love this business.
I met the woman who would become my wife.
She was a waitress, an actress.
She actually left on day two to go get an
acting job and I couldn't stop thinking about
having just seen her for one second.
I met the neighborhood in which Union Square
Cafe, and Gramercy Tavern, and so many of
our restaurants have been, and I met my career.
That was a major, major pivot point, but it
just shows you so many things in life are
those moments.
I mean, the fact that none of this ever would've
happened if I had not gone to Trinity College,
for example, because that's where I met my
friend, and I was, oh for three applying.
I was such a screw up in high school, I applied
to only three colleges.
I was rejected from two and waitlisted at
Trinity, and I had to get down on my hands
and knees and write the best letter of my
life to get off the wait list to Trinity.
So first of all, that had to happen, and the
only reason that Trinity happened is that
when my dad's business was in Rome, his travel
business, he met Trinity College's lawyer
at dinner one night, and the lawyer said,
"Hey, your son should consider Trinity College."
Which none of us had ever heard of.
So all that stuff, and then by the way, this
friend of mine who introduced me to his restaurant
client, the only reason we ever met is on
the first night that I was at Trinity College,
there was a pickup softball game and there
weren't enough baseball gloves to go around,
and so I lent my glove and I went up to this
guy and accused him of stealing my baseball
glove, and somehow we became friends after
that.
So just all these moments that didn't have
to happen and that it happens in life every
day, and you've just got to pay attention
and just be grateful if you're fortunate enough
to have a good choice based on stuff that
never should have happened in the first place.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
It's so wild.
So I have a number of follow up questions,
which will dig a bit more into a few of these
bits and pieces.
So the first is, and this will lead to a question
about not applying to law school.
When you were working in Rome and you would,
say, have a group of four or five people,
you picked the crankiest and they become your,
not mark, but your objective in the sense
that you're going to turn them into a happy
raving fan by the end.
What were the keys or techniques, what did
you learn over time as most reliable for doing
that for that person?
Danny Meyer: I was probably in five different
schools growing up in St. Louis.
So there was a nursery school, then there
was a public school, then we moved, so there
was another public school.
Then I went to an all boys school because
I wanted to play football on their team.
Then 10th grade came and I wanted to go to
school with girls, so I went to a co-ed school
after that.
So that was five schools.
Then by the time I was 18, now I'm going to
college, so now I'm in six schools by the
time I'm 18.
You've got to learn a lot of social cues along
the way.
I just found that I was really good at kind
of understanding what made people tick and
a really good observer of body language, moods,
et cetera.
And it's not that I didn't have a sense of
myself, where I wasn't like Zelig or a chameleon
changing who I was, but I knew what people
needed.
Kind of a blessing to have found a career
where that is a really useful thing to be
able to do.
And as I said, even before going into the
restaurant business for three years, I was
the top salesman in this company as a young
20-year-old selling against hardened salesmen
from around the country.
I loved it.
I loved getting into my little blue rabbit
and traveling to the worst neighborhoods in
New York where there was the worst amount
of shoplifting, and meeting these people,
these shopkeepers who owned drug stores, bookstores,
clothing stores, fur stores, supermarkets,
and learning to speak their language and making
the sale.
I just loved it.
So I just think that I'm cut out to do this,
and the fact that I happen to love food and
wine as much as I do has certainly helped
a lot.
Tim Ferriss: So I would agree, for sure, that
you are well cut to excel in these various
areas, and there have been various points
where you've had to, for lack of a better
term, maybe operationalize or externalize
yourself so that you could, say, expand in
the restaurant business.
So I'm curious, I mean, you mentioned making
ends meet.
I was going to say, that was Checkpoint, am
I getting that right, or was it Checkpoint
Systems?
Danny Meyer: Yeah, Checkpoint Systems.
Tim Ferriss: Checkpoint Systems.
If you had to try to break down what you did,
let's just say in sales at Checkpoint Systems
that made you so successful so that you could
teach somebody else, does anything come to
mind that you think somebody else could emulate
or principles perhaps they could attempt to
implement if they were in that same job?
Danny Meyer: Well, the first thing is, keep
in mind this was before we had the internet,
but I would still do a lot of research, and
I would still learn as much as I could possibly
learn, not only about the business that I
was trying to sell, but the person who I'd
be meeting with.
What I came to learn very, very quickly in
the New York retail world, and keep in mind,
I was primarily selling to retailers because
that's who had the shoplifting issues, is
that many, many, many of them were either
related to each other.
There was a huge Syrian Jew population.
I'm not just saying that was not the only
population, but I started to develop a sense
for the family trees of either real families
or relationships, and I got to know who knew
who, and I would take that as far as I could
possibly take it.
So I learned early on something that has been
something that I teach our teams, even in
the restaurant business, we call it ABCD so
you can ABCD.
Always be collecting dots so you can always
be connecting dots.
I learned early on that people will take exactly
as much interest in you as they believe you're
taking in them, no more and no less.
So look, I don't want to give away all my
trade secrets here, Tim, but I've listened
to your show for a long time, but I listened
to a couple more segments much more recently
because I really want to understand more about
what makes you tick.
I don't look at it as gaming the system.
I think it's genuinely being curious and being
interested.
So if you're looking for one tip, it's curiosity.
And I should throw in one other thing.
The real trick was that I would pick my, since
I was largely cold calling people or often
cold calling people, I would actually make
my own schedule for where I was going to go
that day based on a restaurant that I wanted
to try in that particular borough or neighborhood
of New York.
I would organize my day around my lunch, or
sometimes I'd organize it.
I even organize it around some guy who would
bring in lobsters in Brooklyn at exactly 2:00
in the afternoon, and I'd go get his lobsters
and bring them home to cook.
But it's in a weird way, I was developing
two careers at the same time without even
thinking about it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you were collecting dots
in a few different areas at the same time,
and also giving yourself, it seems like, small
rewards, which would probably give you more
endurance in doing what you were doing in
terms of gathering or organizing your schedule
around those lunch spots.
Tim Ferriss: How did you navigate the conversation,
and how did your parents respond to the conversation
related to not applying to law school?
Danny Meyer: Well, it was easy at first because
I didn't tell them.
I kind of sidetracked and side stepped.
I finally one day got the courage to say that
I wanted to be a chef.
They knew I loved to cook.
Now you may say, well, how would you get the
courage to say you wanted to be a chef but
not to be a restaurateur?
Well, in fact, I thought I did want to be
a chef.
I had seen at that point, there were a number
of really well educated people who had gone
into the culinary profession, and chefs were
starting to become kind of well known.
Keep in mind, this was way before the Food
Network, but you know, you had people like
Alice Waters who had gone to Berkeley, you
had Jeremiah Tower who had gone to Harvard,
Joyce Goldstein on the West Coast, Mark Miller,
on and on and on.
There's probably like 15 of them, and Wolfgang
Puck had become a household name.
Paul Prudhomme in New Orleans had become a
household name.
So I finally gathered the courage to say,
"I think I want to be a chef."
And by the way, in these days, I spent almost
all of my time walking around the city looking
at menus on restaurants.
I memorized every menu.
I ate at many of the restaurants.
I would go back to Italy many, many times,
not just when I was a tour guide working for
my dad, but until I was 21 years old, I could
travel anywhere Pan Am flew for $44 round
trip, thanks to my dad's travel business.
And so I was constantly going to restaurants
and learning and learning and learning.
And, anyway, so I finally said, "I'm going
to be a chef."
And so my dad was kind of open to it, my mom
maybe a little bit less so, but I went for
it.
My dad actually connected me with two of the
Relais & Châteaux colleagues of his in Bordeaux.
He said, "Look, I know you want to go to Italy,
but in Italy, they basically cook food with
three ingredients, and that's the genius of
Italian cooking.
But if you really, really want to learn to
cook, you've got to go to France.
So I said, "Well, let me do both."
So I spent time in Rome, Bologna, Sardinia,
Milan.
And then my dad did connect me with a restaurateur
in Bordeaux named [foreign language].
And he had two restaurants in Bordeaux.
One was called La Réserve, and the other
was was called Dubern, D-U-B-E-R-N.
The day before I got to La Réserve, they
had lost their second Michelin star.
Now chefs have actually gone off the deep
end for less because Michelin stars were everything
for the French.
And so I get there and everybody in the kitchen
is completely dejected.
And I'm this guy who doesn't know anything
about cooking and who is he and how did he
get in our kitchen and why are they letting
him live with the chef?
And the good news was that after a couple
days, a bunch of people in that kitchen left
because they did not want their resume to
say one star.
Tim Ferriss: To be tarnished.
Danny Meyer: So they figured if they left
with two stars on the resume, they'd be fine.
And so all of a sudden, I started to get some
opportunities, some really big opportunities,
like chopping shallots and opening oysters
and pulling feathers out of pigeons to prepare
them.
And here was the big one.
I got to cook family meal, which that's a
big deal to get to cook for all the other
cooks.
And I was doing some of my family's favorite
recipes.
I'll never forget when I made barbecued ribs.
[foreign language 00:34:21] They didn't even
know how to eat these things.
It was just a great, great experience.
They took me to oyster beds, they took me
to chateaus in Bordeaux.
They took me to places where they made sausage.
They took me on one of my favorite days of
my life, a day that the restaurant was closed
to go hunting for wild pigeons called [inaudible].
Just a great life experience.
Tim Ferriss: I thought that it might be helpful
to people listening, and I'd certainly love
to hear your thoughts on, for lack of a better
way to put it, free work.
So in the food world, you have people who
will stage, and maybe you could describe what
that means.
But my understanding, based on our mutual
friend Bill Gurley's speech at UT, I think
it's called "Runnin' Down a Dream," might
have a slightly different title to it, but
I recommend everybody see it.
There's a 10-minute segment on your arc, and
he presents it really well.
And he talks about how you went from star
salesman at Checkpoint Systems and then, over
time, got to zero and then kind of went upside
down because I think some of these restaurants
asked you to pay them for the privilege of
working there.
Could you just speak to the logic or thinking
behind that?
Maybe it's as simple as, "Hey, I didn't have
a choice and I really wanted to do this,"
but it seems to me that a lot of younger generations
now have the impulse to say, "I want to be
paid what I'm worth."
And I see a lot of wisdom and value in the
secret weapon that a lot of young people have
when they don't have a lot of money, they
have a lot of time, which is working for free
and learning a lot.
Would you be able to share any thoughts that
you have on that?
Danny Meyer: In our industry, there's a sense
that you really, if you want to dig your roots
and build a career, you should learn from
the best.
And how do you get your foot in the door with
the best?
So you were willing to work for nothing.
The only time I ever had to pay anybody was
this cooking teacher in Milan who told me
that she was the Julia Child of Italy, which
she certainly was not the Julia Child of Italy.
I paid her my money and moved on.
But I did many, many stages where I was not
paid anything.
And as I told you, the one that I did in New
York City, I was paid 250 bucks a week, which
kind of laughable.
That's what a waiter makes in half of a night
in New York City these days.
So, look, I just think that if I've learned
one thing, it took me 10 years to open a second
restaurant and today we'll probably open two
Shake Shacks somewhere in the world.
If I've learned any one thing is that there's
a benefit to being a little bit patient and
try to grow where you're planted.
And I think that as life is accelerated for
so many reasons, technology being primary
amongst those, I think that people feel like
there has to be a beginning, middle, and an
end that all gets resolved within a 30-minute
sitcom.
And that's just not how life works.
And I think that if you can do time, paid
or not, but really learn what it is you're
trying to do and not scratch the surface and
move on too quickly, it really pays big dividends.
Now, there were reasons it took me 10 years
to open a second restaurant.
Primary one was I didn't want to go bankrupt.
And since I had seen my dad go through two
different bankruptcies, one in my teens and
one when I was about 20-something, I forget
how old I was.
And I always a associated his bankruptcies
with expansion.
And I assumed that that was the business thing
he wanted to avoid was expansion.
And I didn't want to end up like my dad.
I just said, "There's no way I'm ever going
to open a second restaurant because I don't
want that to happen."
And the silver lining in that, even though
eventually after my dad died and I got some
therapy and the first thing I learned was,
"Hey, guess what, you're not your dad.
And number two, there's a whole lot of businesses
that have expanded and that wasn't the reason
they went bankrupt.
In fact, they didn't go bankrupt."
But the silver lining was I really learned
my business.
I really learned it.
That was probably the reason it took us five
years to open a second Shake Shack.
I didn't want to expand too quickly and I
did not want anything bad to happen.
But guess what?
We've learned our business.
Tim Ferriss: This might seem like a naive
question, but what does learning the business
look like?
Because there's experience and then there's
developing expertise.
Some people can repeat the same mistakes every
year for 20 years straight, and then there's
learning a lot.
And those are two different —
Danny Meyer: Yeah.
Every business is made up of five stakeholders.
And so when I say learning the business, it's
learning as much as you possibly can about
how to motivate all five of your stakeholders
to root for your success.
That's what you want.
And so the best way to motivate all five of
those stakeholders to root for your success
is to make sure that they believe you're on
their side first.
So it was learning who's our staff?
That was our first stakeholder.
Who are they?
Who are the best staff we could possibly have?
Who are our guests?
And I mean really learning about them.
And to this day, to this very day, I end every
single night reading all the reservation reports
for all of our restaurants so I know who's
dining in our restaurants tomorrow.
And then if I stay up really late, I read
all the after service reports or I'll do that
first thing in the morning to find out and
how did all those experiences go?
And I weigh in.
And to this day I'm connecting dots because
I care about who our guests are.
This one knows that one.
Seat them near each other.
This one has just published a book.
Make sure to go buy that book and have it
on the maitre d' stand so they can sign it.
I care about that stuff as much as I've ever
cared about it.
But it also means getting to know the community
in which you do business because why should
your community root for your success if you're
not investing in your community?
Same thing goes true of our suppliers.
Get to know your suppliers.
You want the best product.
You can't have the best business if your raw
products are no good.
I learned that lesson, by the way, from my
grandmother.
Very, very important.
I loved the cooking in her home.
And I'll never forget when I asked for her
tomato sauce recipe and she said, "I'll give
you the recipe, but I'll tell you one thing
right now.
It's never going to be any better than the
worst ingredients you put into it.
And number two, those ingredients themselves
won't be any better than how well you treat
them after you buy them.
So you'd better get the best tomatoes, which
in New York, York is a two-month season."
It's August and September.
And even if you get the best tomatoes, you'd
better not throw them in the back corner of
the walk-in refrigerator and bruise them so
that they lose their sugar.
Treat them the right way.
Well, guess what?
Same thing goes for people.
You can have the best recipe in the world
for how you hire people, but you'd better
pick the best tomatoes.
You'd better treat them the right way if you
want the best sauce.
So I've just learned so many lessons.
It's amazing how many life lessons actually
apply to learning your business.
Another great one that my grandmother taught
me.
When I was a little kid growing up in St.
Louis, my favorite moment was March — March
and April — because spring came kind of
early to St. Louis.
And that's when my grandmother would plant
her flower garden.
She had a amazing green thumb.
Well, keep in mind, she lived in an urban
apartment building, which was a skyscraper
in St. Louis at six stories tall and her apartment
building gave her a plot of land in the parking
lot that was probably 20 feet long by about
four feet wide.
And she called it Carbon Monoxide Gardens.
And so every spring she would invite me to
come help her plant her garden for the summer.
And this would always be probably late March,
something like that.
And this probably started when I was six years
old or something like that.
And she gave me my gardening gloves and she
taught me early on to figure out which were
the weeds.
And kind of like that scene from Tom Sawyer
and Huckleberry Finn, she was basically having
me do all of her free labor weeding the garden.
So I learned to pick all the weeds.
So now, by the time I'm about nine, I go down
there for my annual spring visit, and now
it's probably April or May because I would
do this as the garden would keep growing.
And she said, "Now I'm going to teach you
the real secret to how you have a great garden."
And so I go for the weeds dutifully, and she
said, "Nope."
She takes my hand, gently pulls it off the
weeds, and she hands me a watering bucket
with something in it.
I have no idea what was in it.
And she says, "I'm going to teach you how
to water the flowers, because if you really
want to get rid of the weeds, the best thing
you need to do is water the flowers because
the flowers will provide a canopy that will
actually prevent the weeds from getting the
sunlight that they actually need."
So, voila, best business lesson ever because
I spent the first 10 years of my career almost
exclusively focused on trying to motivate
problem employees to be better, like the weeds.
And what I learned was that our employees
are like sunflowers.
They will turn wherever the sun is.
And if I'm spending all of my attention on
the weeds, I'm actually pulling the gravitational
force that way.
And my grandmother's lesson was right.
If I water the flowers and spend more time
with the people who maybe I've taken for granted
because they're doing such a great job, they
actually crowd out the weeds and the weeds
take care of themselves.
Tim Ferriss: I'm definitely going to ask you
more questions about hiring with some hypothetical
situations, but before I move on, the five
stakeholders.
Did you list them?
And I think it was employees, guests, community,
suppliers, investors in roughly the order
that you would, or did, weigh them in your
restaurants?
Danny Meyer: Exactly.
Exactly that order.
It took a long time to figure that out.
Every business has those same stakeholders.
You get to pick in which order you're going
to prioritize them in.
And when I went to college, and I took exactly
one econ course, Econ 101, and of course you
learn about Adam Smith and we studied Milton
Friedman, the guy from the University of Chicago,
and he was like, "Take care of the investor
and everything else takes care of itself."
So I had that voice on my shoulder, but also
one of the first jobs I had after college,
I was the Cook County Field Coordinator for
John Anderson's independent run at the presidency
in 1980.
And leave it to me to work for the independent
guy, not the Republican, not the Democrat.
But a hundred percent of the people who reported
to me — that job, by the way, I got 214
bucks a week, but a hundred percent of the
people who reported to me were volunteers,
and most of them were older than I was because
I was only 22.
And I didn't have any way to motivate them
with money.
I couldn't give them a raise, couldn't dock
them their pay.
So I learned such a crucial lesson, which
is that, if someone's volunteering, the only
way to motivate them is to have a higher purpose.
We're all doing this because we agree with
this bigger idea.
And so I basically took that idea to work
with me when I first became a restaurateur.
And, again, everybody was getting paid, but
at least half the people were older than I
was, and I was learning what it was like to
be a leader, to be the boss.
And I basically, to this day, treat all of
our employees as if they are volunteers, which
not in the real sense.
You're going to get paid.
But if you're working for me, it means you're
probably good enough to have gotten another
25 job offers at least.
And so, as far as I'm concerned, you're volunteering
to share your gifts with us.
I better give you a higher purpose and reason
for wanting to be here.
And that's when it became clear to me that
our first stakeholder had to be our own employees.
And by the way, I look at this, Tim, like
it's a virtuous cycle.
It's not a totem pole where the employee's
on the top and the investor's on the very
bottom.
It's a virtuous cycle where one input leads
to something even better.
So if you want to have really happy customers,
they shouldn't be the input.
You should have really happy employees, which
I think then leads to a greater chance you're
going to have really happy customers.
If you want to have really happy investors,
you wouldn't want that to be the input, Mr.
Milton Friedman.
You'd want that to be the outcome.
And by the way, what's ultimately the best
way to have happy employees?
Have really happy investors because that's
the only way people are going to get promotions
and raises.
And I've run a business where nobody was getting
promotions and raises and it was not happy.
We had to go out of business when that happened.
Tim Ferriss: I'd like to ask you a question
about writing.
And I'm going to begin with a blast from the
past, which I've kept for a very, very long
time because I think it's so masterfully crafted,
and it's something that you crafted.
And this is a polite decline.
I'm not going to say rejection.
A polite decline when I, via a mutual acquaintance,
close friend of mine, Jeffrey Zurofsky, reached
out to see if you would participate in my
book, Tribe of Mentors.
And the beauty was your response ended up
being incredibly valuable as a polite decline.
So I'm going to be paraphrasing a bit, but
this is what I received, and it was via Jeffrey
who was acting as the yenta/intermediary.
"Jeffrey, greetings and thanks for writing.
I'm grateful for the invitation to participate
in Tim's next book project, but I'm struggling
at this moment to make time ends meet for
all we're doing at USHG, including my ongoing
procrastination with my own writing projects.
I thought carefully about this, and it's clearly
a wonderful opportunity, but I'm going to
decline with gratitude.
Know the book will be a big success!
Thanks again.
Danny."
So this is so noteworthy for me because there
are many ways you can decline something that
are likely to upset someone or don't do anything
to offset the potential for someone being
upset.
I came away from receiving this just laughing
and wanting to get better at writing polite
declines because I felt better.
I felt better about you, I respected you more
after receiving that.
How did you learn to write?
How did you improve or develop your written
communication?
Danny Meyer: I can't believe it.
I can't believe you pulled that letter out.
That's wild.
And you know what?
I do that almost every day.
But I wouldn't do it if it weren't genuine.
I wouldn't have gone to the trouble of saying
all that stuff if it weren't genuine.
I've always loved writing.
My dad was an amazing editor.
He was actually the managing editor of the
newspaper at Princeton, The Daily Princetonian,
and he took great pride in marking up anything
I ever wrote.
And I care.
I love writing.
I love expressing myself.
But also, I think more to your point, it's
not the quality of the writing as much as
it is the sentiment behind it, which is that
—
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Danny Meyer: — gets back to what we were
saying earlier.
If somebody cared enough to reach out their
hand and say, "I want to shake hands with
you," that's what that was.
Or they reach out to give you a hug, what
are you going to do?
Just become a tree and not hug them back?
And I think that I've learned a very, very
important lesson.
In fact, I'd be curious, and you'll probably
know, I care so much about letting someone
know, if I do appreciate an invitation, but
I just genuinely can't do it, I care that
they know that their invitation mattered to
me so much so that I sometimes procrastinate
writing that note and learn the hard way that
sometimes my mind and my heart are at war
with each other.
My mind knows I shouldn't do it.
My heart really wants to do it.
And if that translates to making you or Jeffrey
wait too long to get that response, it doesn't
really matter what I wrote.
So I'm really curious to know when Jeff's
invitation came and how many days went by
before I responded.
My bet is more days than there should have
been.
Tim Ferriss: I don't have the dates, but I'll
take a look.
Has your approach to that type of polite decline
changed over time?
Do you have other language that you like to
use?
And, again, this is not to imply, to your
point earlier, that this is disingenuous.
The assumption is, and I believe, that it's
genuine, but have you found —
Danny Meyer: And it's really hard.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it is.
Danny Meyer: It's really hard.
It takes time because what most people do,
sadly, is they just delete the invitation
or they just ignore it.
So I think it kind of falls into a couple
camps here.
So number one is, is this something I really
want to do?
Number two, if I really want to do it, can
I do it?
So that's easy.
Look at your calendar.
And number three, is this something that I
feel like I should do?
And then, of the shoulds, there's another
couple buckets, which is is it a should because
I have to, or is it a should because it's
good?
I've gotten into most trouble on the shoulds.
If I really, really want to do something,
like I really wanted to have this conversation
with you today, I'm the guy that reached out
to you.
And I love when I get a spark of something
that I really want to do.
But many, many times, the invitations come
in, I get a lot from politicians, we support
this or that, I get a lot from speaking opportunities,
et cetera.
And I'm not complaining.
I'm very, very fortunate.
But if it's a should, I learned this lesson
from the restaurateur Jeremy King, who's in
London.
Great guy.
And he said, "The shoulds are what have gotten
me in the most trouble."
And I ask myself a simple question.
If this thing were tonight, because it's generally
something four, five, six months from now,
but if this thing were tonight, is this something
I would be excited to do or would I roll my
eyes and go, "Oh, man, look what I have to
do tonight."
And so by making it in the very present, that's
really helped me a lot with the shoulds.
And then I just feel like it's not my obligation
to say yes to everybody, but I do care.
I genuinely care.
If somebody had the courtesy to invite me
to do something, they deserve the courtesy
of a gracious response.
All they're guilty of is saying, "I'm interested
in you."
How bad is that?
That's a compliment.
Tim Ferriss: It can be really challenging,
and I just want to give you kudos again for
an incredibly beautifully crafted polite decline
that I was, might sound bizarre, but thrilled
to receive.
I really admired it so much that I've kept
it on hand.
And I ask about writing because I find that
you seem to pay a lot of attention to language
and communication and clarity.
And my attention was drawn, in doing homework
for this conversation, to questions.
Now you can't believe everything that you
read on the internet, so I do want to fact
check this, but I found a list of six qualities
Danny Meyer looks for when hiring, that is.
And the first is, I'm just going to read through
these and then you can correct as needed or
expand as needed, but I'm going to get to
a few at the end, there are only six, that
have questions associated.
So number one: Kind eyes.
"Eyes don't lie, kind eyes is a hell of a
start!"
Curiosity.
Does this person see themselves as a finished
product or are they looking to continually
learn?
Three: Work ethic.
You can teach someone how to decant a bottle
of wine but can't teach them to see opportunities
to do more.
Now we're going to get into some questions.
So four: Empathy.
Is this the kind of person the entire team
is going to want to be around?
Ask: "On a scale of 1 - 10, tell me how lucky
are you?"
So I'm curious about that.
Self-awareness.
Can this person read their own weather report?
Ask: "What is the single biggest misconception
people have about you?"
And then integrity/trust.
You ask, "Name something that happened to
you before the age of 12 that has changed
your life forever."
If you were hiring for your first restaurant
today, would you ask some of these questions,
look for these six things, or would you modify
this?
Danny Meyer: I would absolutely look for those
things.
In fact, I've checked them with myself year
after year, and there's not one of them I
would take off the list.
I want to work with people who are kind people,
who genuinely are optimistic people.
I'm not really excited working with skeptics
who just see what could go wrong all the time.
You do need to surround yourself with, look,
I'm a cock-eyed optimist.
I'm so damn optimist that I basically see
the wine glass as half full even before I
pull the cork on the bottle, but it's been
important for me to surround myself with people
who at least ask me some tough questions.
So I want kind optimists.
I definitely want curious people who look
at each — I don't want know-it-alls.
I want learn-it-alls.
I don't want someone who's already a finished
product.
It's not fun, especially if you're trying
to make your business better every day.
I definitely want people who have an excellent
work ethic.
I don't mean to the point of being sick because
we can all push it too far, but it's not fun
to be on a team where everybody's really bringing
their best and there's a couple people just
putting in a C-level effort.
That doesn't work.
And I definitely want empathetic people, people
who understand the wake they leave in their
path, who care about how they make other people
feel just as much as they care how other people
feel.
So, yeah, and definitely I want self-aware
people and I want people with integrity.
So a hundred percent of those.
The one thing I would add that has really,
really come to light for me is I want people
who just love to win because that's not really
captured in any of the six that I mentioned
earlier.
Wanting to be a champion.
You look at the best athletes in sports.
Sure, they have God-given physical ability,
but they also had to train like crazy.
You don't get to be the Kentucky Derby winner
without — you've got your blood lines, but
you also had to train like crazy.
You don't get to be Serena Williams without
the blood lines, but you don't also get to
be Serena Williams without working incredibly
hard.
Or Michael Jordan.
Whoever it is you want to talk about.
So I look for that.
I'm really interested to know the motivation
behind what makes someone competitive.
And I basically have four buckets.
First of all, there's acompetitive people.
They're great people.
They just don't wake up every day saying,
"I've got to win.
I'm dying to win."
Tim Ferriss did not get to be Tim Ferriss
without desiring to be the best.
I know that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm very competitive.
Danny Meyer: That doesn't necessarily come
across, but —
Danny Meyer: I know that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, very competitive.
Danny Meyer: And that doesn't necessarily
come across, but you're not a competitive,
I can tell you that.
Then the other three buckets I look for, and
this helps me with someone's self-awareness
as well, is to understand, assuming that you
are motivated to be a champion at what you
do, what is your primary motivation for wanting
to compete to win?
And I find there's basically three buckets.
Sometimes people have a little bit of each,
but there's the — you know that picture
of Muhammad Ali standing triumphantly over
Sonny Liston —
Tim Ferriss: I do.
Danny Meyer: — whose back is on the mat
with his fist up in the air?
So I can pretty much tell you that Muhammad
Ali was primarily motivated by a love for
beating someone else.
That felt really good to him.
That's not a bad thing or a good thing, it
just is what it is.
Then you've got, imagine this photograph of
John McEnroe with his headband on and his
long curly hair, yelling at the umpire, "You've
got to be kidding me."
That man hated to lose.
It wasn't so much, "I'm motivated by who I'm
going to beat," it's like, "I will not be
seen losing."
And then, the third image I would have would
be a great Olympian, let's say Usain Bolt,
and his leg is outstretched with the veins
popping, trying to get that extra inch or
that extra half second off of his time or
whatever.
And that guy is, he's out there, his primary
motivation, he wants to exceed his own personal
best.
He's competing with himself.
So by knowing these questions, this is something
that I would absolutely want to add today,
because I know that I want to be the best
and I can't do it by myself.
So I've got to stock my team with people who
look at every day as an opportunity, not for
perfection, because I think perfection is
stupid, it's impossible, it's a recipe for
unhappiness.
But I do look for people who look at every
day as an opportunity to honor whatever they
did yesterday, and figure out how to do it
a little bit better today.
That's the journey of excellence.
Tim Ferriss: How do you assess, this might
sound silly, work ethic?
Is it by trialing someone?
Because everyone's going to be on best behavior
and saying, "Oh, my biggest flaw is I just
work too hard."
That type of college application nonsense
in a job interview.
Do you have particular ways that you would
approach assessing that proactive work ethic?
Not just doing what you give them, but thinking
about what else they could do?
How do you think about assessing?
Danny Meyer: Well, I basically define it as,
you've now learned how to do the job, but
only you can determine if it matters to you
to do it as well as it can be done.
And you can see it in people.
There's so many ways we can all take shortcuts.
The obvious things are, did you show up?
Did you show up on time?
Did you show up shaven, if that's what your
job is in the dining room, let's say?
Did you press your shirt, or just take it
easy and get that extra third use out of your
shirt where you don't really care what it
looks like?
And you see this in sports all the time, and
I think sports has so much to teach us.
Number one is, I think, in my mind, hospitality
is a team sport.
We rely on each other.
It doesn't matter whether you had a bad night
or not, you're not expected to go strike out
if you're a baseball player.
It doesn't matter whether you woke up on the
wrong side of the bed or not, you're not expected
to let a ball roll through your legs at shortstop.
Well, it's the same thing in my business.
Your job is to make the rest of your team
better, and your job is to make the rest of
your team better, whether you're on the field
or in the dugout.
And I've got a quick story that I learned
so much from other people.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, please.
Danny Meyer: You've probably heard of Theo
Epstein.
In fact, maybe you've even interviewed him
at some point.
Tim Ferriss: I have not actually.
I'm going to plead ignorance.
I will broadcast it.
Danny Meyer: So Theo Epstein is the youngest
general manager in, I think, the history of
Major League Baseball.
And he was hired at a very, very young age
to take over being the general manager of
the Boston Red Sox, who had not won anything
for decades and decades and decades.
And they talked about the Yankee Curse or
whatever the hell it was, but for whatever
reason, they couldn't win.
He comes, he's the general manager, revamps
the team, and of course, they win their first
title.
I want to say it was in 2004.
Actually, I don't want to say that because
if that's the case, it was against my St.
Louis Cardinals.
But he then went on to go win a couple others
for them, and then he leaves to go to the
Chicago Cubs.
And the Chicago Cubs, guess what?
They have not won a World Series forever.
He revamps their team, Chicago Cubs win a
World Series for the first time in all these
years.
So now, this wonder, Theo Epstein, is asked
by a lot of people, and he basically, "What's
the secret here?"
And you've got to understand, baseball is
a game of statistics.
They measure everything.
There's statistics I don't even begin to understand,
but 100 percent of those statistics are what's
happening on the field.
So running, caught stealing, your fielding
percentage, your batting percentage, your
batting percentage with runners on base, your
batting percentage against left-handers, right-handers,
on and on and on and on.
Half the game of baseball is played while
you're sitting on the bench.
Your team is in the field, you're on the field.
When your team is at bat, you're on the bench.
And so, the real question is, how do you measure
what your impact is on the rest of the team
when you're in the dugout?
Did you help the rest of your teammates get
better?
So I've been watching this guy, Theo Epstein,
trying to learn from him.
And finally, I have the chance to meet him
once.
And he had given a talk at a conference I
attended, and it was the year that there was
a big hurricane in Houston.
I want to say it was Hurricane Maria, but
I'm probably wrong about that.
And this was a week after the World Series.
Houston won the World Series that year, beating
the Los Angeles Dodgers.
And he was still with the Cubs, the Cubs had
lost to the Dodgers in the Championship Series
that year.
So the team that the Cubs lost to, went on
into the World Series and lost to Houston.
So I go up to Theo Epstein, and I finally
get a chance to talk to this guy who I've
been learning from from afar, and I ask him
the stupidest question in the world, and I
go, "Who were you rooting for?
I've got to know, who were you rooting for
in the World Series?
Were you rooting for Houston because you felt
bad for the city, because they just had this
hurricane and you wanted to see something
nice happen for Houston?
Or were you rooting for the Dodgers because
it would make the Cubs look better if the
team they lost to went on to become the champion?"
And he looks at me like I'm from Mars, and
he goes, actually very politely, he goes,
"Actually, neither one of those things.
I was absolutely rooting for the Dodgers to
win, but not because it would make the Cubs
look better.
It's because, if the Dodgers win the World
Series, I know that the Cubs have to face
them eight times next year during the season.
And if they win the World Series, they're
going to be like every other team that wins
the championship, and they're not going to
do the things they need in the off season
to improve their team, and that's going to
make them easier for us to compete with next
year."
And I went, "Shit, that is such a great lesson."
Because it's like, when you think you're doing
well or you think you're on top of whatever
profession, that's the time you've got to
break the glass and you've got to start over.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Danny Meyer: And that's when I think most
of us, and it's not just laziness and it's
not just sitting on your laurels, you think
it's great.
But the world keeps moving, and if you don't
keep moving with it, you will definitely not
keep up.
Tim Ferriss: That is a great story.
And I'd be curious to know, did you dig into
or have a chance to study how he assessed
things that were not captured in the usual
stats, people showing up early to practice,
maybe staying later, practicing A, B, or C?
Were there any other particular approaches
that you've gleaned from studying him or speaking
with him?
Danny Meyer: It was all intuitive to him and
it's the stuff I was looking at on our team.
The character, like in my business, this is
going to sound really trite, but our staff,
the cooks and the servers sit down and have
what's called family meal before every lunch
service and before every dinner service.
And it's an opportunity for people to come
together, stop.
We call it family meal.
We are a business, not a family, but you can
watch during that time, you can just watch
who's bringing motivating thoughts to the
table, who's actually bringing outside ideas
to the table, who's asking questions.
You can tell who's bringing the conversation
down.
There's always someone on every team it who's
the, "Ain't it bad?"
person.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Danny Meyer: That's not someone we really
want in the dugout.
I want people who are like, "Just imagine
if we..."
I want that person, "Just imagine if we could
do this," kind of person.
But I didn't study that in Theo, except I've
watched how — before Theo Epstein, the most
famous general manager was a guy named Billy
Beane who famously rebuilt the Oakland As.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
The antagonist of Moneyball for people who
might [inaudible].
Danny Meyer: Exactly.
And I think what Theo did was, he added the
emotional aspect to the technical aspect.
Tim Ferriss: Mmm.
So let's say you have someone on your team
you don't want in the dugout, and let's say
there's a reality TV show where you put on
a Groucho Marx makeup kit, and you go and
you're starting a new restaurant.
You can use all the knowledge you have, but
you can't use the contacts, you can't use
the bankers and the financiers or whatever
you might have had access to before, and you
have to let somebody go.
How do you make that decision?
Is it made quickly?
Have you set rules for yourself as to how
to go about doing that?
And then, what is the language or approach
that you might use?
Danny Meyer: Well, I've gotten much, much
better at it as the years have gone by.
I'll never forget the first people I had to
fire when I was 27, 28.
I'd lose sleep for days, literally days.
I even went on my honeymoon knowing that I
was going to have to fire someone when I came
back from my honeymoon, and I really regret
that.
I really regret that I hadn't done it ahead
of time, because that's not something that
I should have been thinking about on the honeymoon.
And the early days, I really looked at our
business as if it were a family.
And again, the way I grew up, it's like my
job was to keep the family together.
And I would be great at, if somebody wasn't
working out at one position, I'd find a different
position to move them to.
Anything to keep them, because it felt like
I had somehow failed if someone was leaving
our company.
And I was really, really good, on the other
hand, at rewarding great performance, but
I was pretty damn bad and/or slow at exiting
people who shouldn't have been on the team.
And so a big thing happened over time, and
not too far in the rearview mirror either.
And that was this thing that I've already
alluded to, which is that, number one, it's
a business, not a family.
And one of the great things about the restaurant
business is that it does feel family-ish to
people because you spend so many damn hours
working with each other, but it's not a family.
And so, it's a good thing, but it's a double-edged
sword, because when you fire somebody from
the family, also known as your restaurant,
you have to ask yourself, "What will this
do to the fabric of that group?
That troop that's working together?"
So I was able to come up, with the help of
some restaurateurs in California, they gave
me this model that I just absolutely love,
and we've turned it into something that we
do.
And they basically created a four quadrant
thing.
You've seen these axes many times with a Y-axis
and an X-axis.
And in one of the quadrants, there's the word,
"Can."
Let's say the upper left-hand, it says, "Can."
And then, in the upper right, it says, "Can't."
And then, in the bottom left, it says, "Will."
And in the bottom right, it says, "Won't."
So you basically have someone's technical
abilities, the can and can't, and then you
have somebody's emotional willingness or aptitude,
and that's will and won't.
And so what we've been able to do, we've actually
created mirrors, which we've put in the locker
rooms of our restaurants, because we're not
trying to keep this a secret.
And the mirror has all four quadrants.
And so, when you go put on your uniform every
day, you get to look at yourself in the mirror
if you so choose and see this quadrant.
So basically, if you have someone who will
but can't, that's a very different thing than
someone who won't and can't.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Danny Meyer: Or if you have someone who — I
could go through all of them, but what we've
basically done, Tim, is that we have an action
point and a timeframe for each one of those.
So if you've got somebody who can and will,
I want to celebrate that person, I want to
replicate that, but I really want to pay at
— those are my flowers, I really want to
water them.
Too often we ignore those people because,
"Oh, that's easy.
We don't have to worry about Johnny because
he always gets it right."
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Danny Meyer: You really want to water those
flowers and celebrate them.
If you have someone who can't but will, I'm
going to coach them, and I don't mind saying
this, but the wick on my candle is pretty
long for someone who will.
Because if you can teach them how to do the
thing and they're willing to do it and they've
got the right approach, the right hospitality
attitude, once they learn how to do it, you're
going to have a loyal employee for life because
you stuck with them.
Now, on the other hand, so let's say that's
a six-month wick on my candle.
Let's say you've got someone who can't and
won't.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Danny Meyer: I'm going to put the candle underneath
their rear end, and they're going to have
to learn that this isn't working.
And that's going to be a very, very short,
that's got to be a short window, because the
longer that person stays on the team, everyone
else on the team says, "Why should I try?
If they keep batting that person in the lineup,
instead of benching them or sending them to
the minor leagues, why should I try?"
The hardest one I find is the can but won't.
That's the person where you just go, "You're
way better than this, but for some reason,
you're just choosing not to bring it here."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Danny Meyer: And so that's going to have a
pretty short life as well.
But by actually naming all four of those things,
it really, really helps us to have these conversations.
And we tell people up front, so you're not
having, they see that mirror, so it's not
the first time you're having this conversation.
It gives you a language to say, "Here's where
you are right now, and it's not working."
And I'll say probably the greatest lesson
I've learned about anything has been really
trying to understand, how do you scale culture?
And I've come up with this equation in my
own mind that took me a long time to get to.
I used to think that by rewarding the behaviors
I wanted, that was the best way to fuel the
culture I wanted.
And now, I look at it a little bit differently,
because that's turning a blind eye sometimes
to the behaviors I don't want.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Danny Meyer: So I've now learned that the
culture you have in your organization is the
sum of all the wanted behaviors that you celebrate,
minus all the unwanted behaviors that you
tolerate.
And I've learned that the hard way, because
people think I'm full of crap, they can read
anything I write about our culture, et cetera.
But if I'm tolerating behaviors that don't
promote either the excellence or wellbeing
of the team, then everything I've done on
the positive side should be called into question.
Tim Ferriss: How might you, these days, having
had much more practice since your honeymoon,
if you had to let somebody go, or you wanted
to maybe suggest languages someone might use,
but you could make it personal, how might
you phrase that conversation?
Danny Meyer: Well, first of all, it shouldn't
be the first time you've had the conversation.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Danny Meyer: There's nothing worse than when
somebody feels like they got whacked in the
back of the head, and they're just shocked
because you had never had the conversation.
You hadn't had the tough conversation that
said, "Either your performance or your behavior,
it's one of the two…"
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Danny Meyer: "Aren't measuring up."
And that's another reason that we have to
be really clear about what excellent performance
looks like, and what wanted behaviors are,
which we're very, very clear about.
And by being up front with people and not
having this be the first time you're having
the conversation, it takes a lot of the emotion
out of it.
It doesn't mean someone's going to be happy,
but it basically sounds like — actually,
something that I've said on a few occasions,
not in the time I'm actually exiting somebody,
but in the time leading up to it, is I use
what I call the jigsaw puzzle analogy.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Danny Meyer: We've all done jigsaw puzzles,
and the more challenging they are, you get
to this point where it's starting to take
some shape, but you still have a lot more
pieces that you haven't put together than
what you have in your little shape there.
And invariably, you're going to come up with
a piece that looks like it's right, and you
put it down and it's almost right.
It's so almost right that you keep jiggering
it around to make it right, even though you
know it's not right, and the piece knows it's
not right.
And what starts to happen is, the paper on
top of the jigsaw piece starts to fray a little
bit.
And in fact, the jigsaw puzzle, if you keep
trying, starts to fray.
Well, that's what we do too often with employees
that are almost right, but they're not really
the right fit, and it ends up not being good
for the puzzle or for the puzzle piece.
So I try to explain that to people.
If you get that conversation with me, chances
are probably 80 percent that the next conversation
is, "You should go.
You're a beautiful jigsaw piece, but you should
probably be part of a different puzzle."
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Danny Meyer: It doesn't make you wrong, doesn't
make you bad, you didn't — now, if it's
someone who actually did something bad, that's
a very different conversation.
It's like, "You cannot work here.
You've betrayed integrity, you've betrayed
someone on our team, you've betrayed one of
our guests, you've betrayed our investors,
whatever."
If you cross any one of our stakeholders,
that's a very different conversation, lack
of integrity.
But if it's just not the right fit, number
one, it shouldn't be the first time they've
heard about it.
And they may not love the conversation.
Who in the world wants to be exited?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Danny Meyer: But I'll tell you one thing I
feel really good about is, we have a pretty
small industry, and invariably, if you're
someone who left our business, on your terms
or on our terms, you're probably going to
be serving me in a restaurant sometime in
New York.
And I feel really good that I never mind seeing
these people.
It just feels like, as long as it's clean
and we were honest with each other, it tends
to work out in the end.
Tim Ferriss: Reading your bio, looking at
the highlights, you've had so many successes,
I would imagine, beyond your wildest dreams
or expectations that you could have had in
your, say, late 20s.
What are some of your favorite failures, or
any favorite failures that come to mind?
And by favorite failures, I mean a failure
that you learned a lot from, that set you
up unexpectedly for later success.
Anything that sticks out, comes to mind, as
a seminal moment.
Danny Meyer: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: A teaching moment.
Danny Meyer: Many, many, many.
Every day we have micro failures.
There's a really good movie called The Best
Exotic Marigold Hotel.
I don't know if you've ever seen it.
Tim Ferriss: I haven't watched it.
Danny Meyer: So it's a terrible title because
I can almost never remember it.
I want to say Carnation, Chrysanthemum, but
it's The Best Exotic Marigold Hotel, takes
place in India.
And there's two great lessons from that, one
of which, I think, answers, there's probably
more than two, but one of my favorite lessons
is that the only real failure is the failure
to try, and that the measure of success is
how we cope with the disappointment.
And so —
Tim Ferriss: I like that latter.
Danny Meyer: I'd say that I was, probably
the first most pivotal experience for me was
closing the first restaurant I ever closed,
which was Tabla, an Indian restaurant.
Interesting that I'm using an Indian film
to talk about this.
But Tabla was about 13 years old, and if I
regret one thing that I wrote in Setting the
Table, it was actually in the very first paragraph
of the book.
And I proudly stated, at this point, we had
been in business for about 20 years, and I
proudly stated how many restaurants we had
opened.
And then, I super proudly stated, "And in
all that time, we've never closed one," as
if closing a restaurant is failure.
And it was the stupidest thing I could have
possibly written because closing a restaurant
is not failing, and it's also nothing to be
ashamed of and nothing to be proud of to keep
a restaurant open forever.
Either it is or it isn't.
So Tabla, I guarantee you, I was so falsely
proud with what I had written, that I kept
Tabla — and I was so afraid of my dad's
— I didn't want to go down the path of being
my dad.
You telling me that I couldn't make something
work here?
Tabla was a great Indian expression with,
in a very groundbreaking way in New York City,
using fresh green market ingredients.
We had a fantastic chef who sadly died during
Covid, Floyd Cardoz.
Groundbreaking restaurant, lived for 13 years,
probably should have closed it at year 11.
We had just hit the Great Recession and we
started to lose money.
It was our biggest restaurant in terms of
numbers of seats.
We had 283 seats on three different dining
rooms, two different levels.
And I was so afraid of closing it, so afraid
of talking to the team and saying we couldn't
make the restaurant work, that I kept it open
for two years longer than I should have.
And that was the restaurant where, for two
years, we had people working out of loyalty.
No one was making a raise, no one was getting
a promotion.
And I finally gathered the courage to do what
I should have done two years sooner.
And I'll never forget the day I said, "Look,
what if we could distinguish ourselves as
much based on how well we closed a restaurant,
as we had with how well we had opened a restaurant?"
And so we started writing a list of, "All
right, what are all the ways that we could
look back on this and say we did it the right
way?"
And first thing was, we told our whole staff.
Now, that sounds, "Well, why is that such
a big...?"
Well, sadly, in our business, sometimes the
first time a staff learns a restaurant's going
out of business is the day they go to work
and see a padlock on the door, because the
restaurant is dead afraid that no one will
work there.
No one wants to stay on a sinking ship.
So we told our staff, quarter of a year ahead
of time, told our landlord, told the community.
We invited all of the alumni of the restaurant
in to come cook with us, so we celebrated
the restaurant.
We hosted job fairs for all of our team members,
not just with us teaching them how to interview
and working potentially in our other restaurants,
but again, inviting famous chefs who had once
cooked with us, or general managers who had
once worked with us, to come in and hire our
staff.
We hosted three fundraisers.
We brought in Indian chefs from around the
country to do a fundraiser for earthquake
victims in India.
We did a fundraiser for Madison Square Park.
So by the time this was done, we paid our
landlord everything.
We actually even paid our investors, I think
they got a 0.1 percent return on their original
investment.
They got all their money back, plus a couple
of pennies.
So if you're going to close a place, at least
that was the way to do it.
And the biggest learning I had was, there's
no shame in closing.
Since closing Tabla, I would say we've probably
opened 15 restaurants, and we've probably
closed another six.
And we had to close about three of them during
Covid.
And I think that learning to fail fast, and
realize that if you didn't tried the thing
in the first place, there would neither have
been a success or failure.
So the real failure would've been not in trying.
But not everything has to go on forever.
The late restaurateur, Joe Baum, had this
great expression that I love and I don't love.
But he used to say that the definition of
a classic restaurant is one that can outlive
its original lease.
And that was a goal of mine for a long, long
time.
And frankly, we've done that with almost all
of our restaurants.
I now have a different goal of my own, which
is, I want our restaurants — and I think
your podcast is this as well, and we all have
songs in our lives that are like this, or
pieces of art or movies or books.
But I want our restaurants to become essential
in people's lives.
I want people to say, "My life got better
because that restaurant existed."
It doesn't matter how long.
And God forbid the restaurant goes out of
business, I want people to say, "I just lost
a little something when that restaurant closed."
There's so many restaurants, dry cleaners,
whatever.
They come and go and it's like, "Who cares?"
There's so many songs, if I never heard it
again, I'd be fine.
But there's this handful of songs that when
I listen to them, I'm grateful for the person
who wrote it, I'm grateful for their life.
My life got better because that song existed,
and I can't even imagine my life if that song
had never been written.
That's my, more than longevity, it's essentiality
that I think matters.
Tim Ferriss: I haven't thought about this
in a really long time, but I still remember
every restaurant and coffee shop in which
I wrote my books, because these locations,
and I took great pains to find the right spot,
became my surrogate family for a period of
time while I worked on these things that of
course became a huge part of my life, continue
to be a huge part of my life.
And even though some of them have gone out
of business, or I shouldn't say gone out of
business, maybe they were just closed, maybe
the decision was made to close, they still
have left this indelible mark in my mind.
And that just brought all of these memories
rushing back like the Pixar movie Ratatouille.
The similar effect just now as you were talking
about that.
And I admire you for being, in my mind, an
experimentalist, running experiments, being
willing to try in terms of testing things.
And I remember, this was some time ago, you
could probably place the timestamp effectively,
but when you experimented with no tipping.
And I would love for you to speak to that
and just discuss lessons learned through that.
And this ties into something we were talking
about a little bit before I recorded, which
was time in Japan where tipping is not a thing,
as an example.
It's just not really part of the culture.
But could you describe what you did and what
you learned?
Danny Meyer: Yeah.
We had faced a major, major shortage in really
good cooks.
This was probably starting in about 2012,
2013, 2014.
And I'll never forget, I went to one of the
restaurants we closed, which was a really
good restaurant, but I think we got a subpar
location for it.
It was called North End Grill.
And I'll never forget going into the restaurant
one night and I said to our general manager,
Kevin, I said, "God, service has gotten really
good here and I'm so proud."
I spoke to four different servers and they
all told me that they had graduated from the
Culinary Institute of America.
And I said, "How are we getting so many people
who want to be professional servers?
This is great."
And he goes, "Boss, I wish I could tell you
that was the truth."
He said, "These are all people who wanted
to be cooks, but they can't afford to be cooks.
And there's like three of them living in a
studio apartment, commuting all the way from
Queens, and we can't pay them any more money
because we don't have any more money to pay
them.
We're trying to give them free Metro cards,
but that's not going to keep them.
So the only way they can make a living is
to be waiters."
And something I'd been thinking about for
many, many years was how much I did not like
the tipping system.
Initially, in the early part of my career,
I didn't like the tipping system because there
would always be a situation in these early
days of Union Square Cafe or Gramercy Tavern
when a tourist from Japan or from France or
Great Britain where there's not a big tipping
culture would either leave no tip or they'd
leave a pretty shitty tip, and it would be
so demoralizing for the waiter.
There was one occasion where one of our waiters
actually chased somebody out onto the sidewalk,
and I was mortified.
It's like, "You cannot do that."
And yet here I was, because the tipping system
where they were getting the adjusted tip minimum
wage back then, which was $2.21, and if they
didn't get a tip, they weren't going to be
able to pay their rent.
So I understood it, but it was just, I hated
it.
But then later, now bringing it up to the
mid 2015 time, I said, "You know what?
I'm so tired of this system where we are legally
prohibited from allowing tips to be shared
between waiters and cooks."
Cooks work at least as hard as waiters, right?
The guy who made the risotto, stirring the
risotto like crazy, didn't work any less hard
than the guy that brought it to the table.
And by the way, if somebody's going to have
truffles shaved on that risotto, and therefore
the price is going to go way up, the waiter
is going to make a whole lot more money and
the cook's going to make zero more money.
And what I had noticed was that every year,
the waiters were making increasingly more
money.
Why?
Well, because menu prices only go up, and
what's a tip if not a multiplier of the menu
price.
And cooks' hourly wages had remained stagnant.
And so you may say, "Well, why don't you just
raise the cook's wage?"
Great.
Every time I raise the cook's wage, I have
to increase the menu prices, which only increases
the disparity because now the tipped employee
makes more.
So I was really tired of trying to argue that
New York state or many, many other states
should change their laws so that tips can
be shared.
And so I said, "Screw it.
I'm just going to take this into my own hands."
And I came to a meeting one day with my senior
leaders and I played one of the worst John
Lennon songs I've ever heard called "Cold
Turkey."
And I said, "I am now declaring tips to be
a drug and we've got to get off this drug.
And if we can't change the rules, we're just
going to stop taking tips."
And we came up with this idea called Hospitality
Included.
And my goal was that we would narrow the gap
between what a cook could not make and what
a server could make.
I didn't want to punish our servers, but I
wanted our cooks to get to make more money
so we could attract more cooks.
Otherwise, New York City as the preeminent
dining capital in America was definitely going
to be threatened.
So we established this idea, did some really,
really hard math, and I'm telling you it's
incredibly hard because you've got three legs
on a stool.
You've got the consumer who's looking at menu
prices that now include everything.
So if you go to a typical restaurant in America,
the menu price has to include the cost of
whatever it is that menu item is, the chicken
and everything that came with it.
It's got to include the cost of the linen,
the flowers, the rent, the insurance.
It includes everything except paying the person
who brought it to your table.
You're going to pay that two and a half hours
after you start your meal.
You're going to get your bill, and then you're
going to go into your other pocket and add
20 percent to that.
But you're going to do it.
So with Hospitality Included, I said everything's
included.
And I purposely called it hospitality, not
service, because the way I look at it is I
want you to feel like you're paying for how
we made you feel.
I want the food to be free, the drink to be
free, and when you look at that big number
at the bottom of your thing, you've got to
feel like, man, I just got a $350 hug.
And so that's why I wanted to call it Hospitality
Included.
And I wanted our staff to understand that.
And so the math was really hard because by
the time I included everything on the menu
price, I don't want to bring our waiters down,
I just want to bring our cooks up by 20 percent.
Oh, by the way, I also wanted to bring our
starting manager salary up because one of
the worst things about the tipping system
is that you cannot afford, in most cases,
to promote yourself from being a great server
to being a manager without taking a 25 percent
pay cut.
And that that's really screwed up, that there's
nowhere to grow.
It's a dead end for waiters unless they're
willing to decide we're going to raise our
manager's wage.
Oh, by the way, we're also going to put in
a retirement plan for our team.
We're going to put in a family leave policy
so that when people are pregnant or people
have a baby, both the birth mother and the
birth father can get up to eight weeks of
paid time off.
We wanted to put all that in the price.
And we didn't want to scare people away from
dining at our restaurants.
And we wanted to leave some money for our
investors.
So we tried it at one restaurant, The Modern.
Really hard, but it worked pretty well.
Amazingly, the guests did not balk.
They loved not having to buy their coat back
from the coat check at the end of the meal
because everything was included.
And then every four or five months, we'd roll
it out at another restaurant.
And we started to see our profits started
to erode a little bit.
But damn it, I was gung-ho on making this
thing work.
Because the good news was we were getting
better cooks and I knew we were doing the
right thing.
There's another thing that I should add is
that in making this choice, we actually had
to forego a million dollars in federal tax
credits, like real money that they pay us.
The federal government pays you to accept
tips.
Tim Ferriss: What?
Danny Meyer: I know.
Does that seem crazy or what?
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Danny Meyer: And once we eliminated tipping,
we had to forego those.
And the reason they did that is that probably
15 years ago when the government realized
they were not collecting a lot of taxes based
on tips because people were hiding what they
were making, they actually brought the restaurant
industry under their cloak.
And they said, "If you guys, for every dollar
tip you report to us that your servers are
making, we will pay you back a certain percentage."
And so that's why they pay restaurateurs to
take tips because they want the tips reported.
So we gave up a million bucks in making this
choice.
I just wanted to do the right thing.
So now all of a sudden Covid happens, we're
basically brought to our knees with no revenues
at all for four months, could have gone out
of business, and had to lay off a huge number
of our team members.
So finally in the summer of 2020, New York
made it legal to open your restaurant with
a certain number of outdoor tables.
You weren't going to make any money, but it
was going to helpfully get the city back up
on its feet.
And I was a big proponent for the city, for
our whole industry.
And I saw this really amazing dynamic happen,
Tim.
The New Yorkers who had been locked up in
their apartments for all these months, unable
to go to restaurants, they could only get
curbside pickup and delivery and that kind
of thing, were so incredibly grateful for
our servers who are willing to come out and
serve them on the sidewalk that they were
literally throwing $20 bills at our servers,
$50, $100 bills to say thank you.
And now I'm telling our servers, "Not only
can you not accept that, but you have to tell
our guests, 'You may not say thank you to
me.'"
After about two weeks of this, I said — and
by the way, we had no vaccine at this point.
So any server working there serving someone
who's not wearing a mask while they're eating,
this was a dangerous time in New York.
And I finally said, this is inhumane, this
is not being on our employees' side.
And so I said, "Guess what?
We are going to resume tipping.
But in so doing, we as a company will start
to pay a percentage of our revenue every night
to our cooks who are tip ineligible."
I don't think that should be our responsibility,
but I did not want to erode the gains we had
made.
And so now that's where we are.
So our servers are making tips, and if we
have a really busy night, our cooks are really
happy, they're benefiting.
They're not just, like in so many restaurants
where on a busy night you're watching the
waiters counting their tips, and the cooks
just perspired more.
That's not right.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
I grew up earning my keep on Long Island as
a kid.
I probably started really young.
God, I was, don't know, 14 or 15, working
as a busboy, and occasionally, if the moment
presented itself, a server at restaurants
on Eastern Long Island.
So I grew up as a townie in the Hamptons,
which has this whole set of stories for another
time.
But I'm wondering, as we think about the four
quadrants that you described earlier, the
can and will, the can't and won't, and the
other permutations, did you run into or how
did you handle a dynamic where people who,
in the previous paradigm, so now I'm talking
about in the Hospitality Included transition,
you're already there, but people who in the
tipping environment had been top performers
contending with that?
So the sunflowers that you want to water.
How did you contend with, if you did, the
dynamic of maybe prior top performers feeling
like they were not going to earn their fair
share?
Danny Meyer: Yeah, it was really tough.
And if you want to take a communications lesson,
just try rolling out Hospitality Included
at your restaurants.
Because tipping is such a deeply held American
way of life, both for the people providing
the service and for the people on the receiving
end.
This was a really tough thing to break, and
not many restaurants joined us in this.
A couple tried and a lot of them folded their
hand well before we did on the whole thing.
But what we did do, and I feel really good
about this, was to do the same thing we do
with our cooks.
So you get a raise based on merit if you're
a cook.
If you're a server, you're getting the same
adjusted minimum wage no matter what you do.
And so we created learning opportunities with
our teams and we had had several tiers of
learning opportunities.
And if you got to a different tier, you got
a higher base wage.
Obviously we were not doing tipping, so you
could actually get a raise through the whole
thing.
So if you looked at our staff, we factored
in longevity, but sometimes the longest serving
servers are the ones that most need to go
because they're just over ripe and they've
lost their spunk.
But we definitely factored in longevity because
here's the thing, the way you make the most
tips in a restaurant is generally through
longevity, because you get classically, the
Thursday, Friday, Saturday shifts, and classically
you don't get the Monday, Tuesday lunch kind
of thing.
What was great, and this was a win for everybody,
was that that while longevity would factor
into your base rate, it did not factor into
your schedule.
And so a lot of people who, in order to make
their money, had to work weekends, sometimes
away from their family, they could actually
have a schedule that was a much better balance
of life.
So there was some wins in this.
But at the end of the day, we just couldn't
make the math work and it just didn't seem
right to tell our staff, "Stop.
You must tell our guests, 'No thank you.'"
That was a pretty awkward thing.
And going back to Japan for a minute, they
have a wonderful culture, very different from
ours, and they call it [foreign language],
which is their word, which is so much more
than hospitality.
It's the providing of hospitality and service
without expectation of any further reward,
in anticipation of someone else's needs.
And it's a beautiful concept, and that's how
that culture has been brought up.
And I've learned a lot from it.
I do believe that the kind of people we hire,
who we call 51 percenters, people who have
a high hospitality quotient, genuinely are
happier themselves when they do something
that makes you feel good, but that's no reason
that they should be penalized relative to
this marketplace in terms of how much money
they can make.
Tim Ferriss: What does 51 percent refer to?
Why 51?
Danny Meyer: Well, we want a hundred percent
employee, just like all of our employees would
like us.
I want to get a hundred on my test.
I think that happened probably three times
when I was a kid, but it doesn't mean I didn't
want it.
And so it's our way of basically saying, "Great,
you want a hundred on your test, here's how
you get it."
Cool thing is there's only two ingredients
in this recipe.
There's your technical performance, how well
you do the job you're paid to do.
The most points you can get for doing it perfectly
is 49.
Then there's your hospitality performance.
That's how did you make everyone else feel
while you were doing it?
That's worth 51 points.
I think we both know 51 is a little more than
49.
I don't want to get a 51 on my test.
That's a failing grade.
If I don't do the technical stuff right, the
food sucks or it took too long, doesn't matter
how nice I am.
I want a hundred.
But I will tell you right now that the only
way I've learned to become essential and burrow
our way into people's hearts is the food better
be damn good.
But more than anything else, you've got to
feel like we're on your side.
And that's where the 51 percent comes in.
Tim Ferriss: Love that.
Danny, I'd love to ask you just a few more
questions, and one that comes to mind, you
seem to be, I have to imagine a reader.
And besides your own books, what books have
you gifted the most to other people, if any
come to mind, or gifted frequently?
Danny Meyer: Well, outside of our cookbooks
and Setting the Table, which is the most gift
I give because someone's got to give it, I
love marketing.
I just love marketing because marketing is
understanding the other person.
Marketing is a dialogue.
It's a lot like hospitality.
And I love Seth Godin's books.
And I would say that I've given many of his
books, but probably the one that I've given
the most is This Is Marketing.
And it comes down to one simple express —
He's just so brilliant at getting to the essence
of what something really is.
And he thinks marketing is when you can convey
that people like us do things like this.
And that sounds so simple, and yet it's so
deep actually.
He understands that people want to feel — I
believe that the biggest longing people have
is to belong.
And so great marketing actually doesn't just
sell you something.
It makes you feel like you belong to a tribe.
So anyway, long answer to your question, but
that would be the one.
Tim Ferriss: Seth also walks the walk.
I really am a huge fan of Seth, and I've gotten
to know him over the years.
Very sweet guy, always will tell you exactly
what is on his mind.
You don't have to guess, which I love.
Makes me pine after the East Coast every once
in a while when I have to deal with the opposite
somewhere in the US.
Danny Meyer: I hope Seth won't mind this story,
but he once told me exactly what was on his
mind.
He had a pretty bad service experience at
one of our restaurants, Maialino, and he told
me.
And I've known Seth for a while, love him.
And I felt so badly, and I said, "I've got
to write a great next chapter on this.
I've got to figure out something."
So I invited Seth to have breakfast with me
at Maialino.
And he didn't want to talk about the service
mishap.
He said, "I gave you the gift, you go deal
with it.
That's your problem.
Go figure that out.
I just want to have a good conversation with
you."
So we had a great breakfast.
And I'm going, all right, finally got Seth
back in my good graces here.
As he's leaving the restaurant after breakfast,
I don't know what happened, but he banged
into our clear door.
The door was so clean that day, he banged
into it and broke his nose.
And I'm going, now what am I going to do here?
Oh, poor Seth.
Anyway, he's a genius and he is the definition
of a mensch.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, he really is.
And he's one of the best people I've ever
met at walking the walk with what he describes
or his values, whether publicly presented
or not.
He's very good at defining his values.
And I don't think he would think of it this
maybe explicitly, but sort of rank ordering
them and then organizing his life, making
decisions about family, business, et cetera,
travel, that are aligned with all of those.
It's very impressive.
I aspire to be better at it, certainly.
Leading off of the very pithy and very, I
think accurate also expression regarding marketing
from Seth, if you could put anything on a
billboard, this is metaphorically speaking,
just to get a message out, could be an image,
could be a quote, could be a word, could be
anything at all, just to convey something
to a very, very large number of people, is
there anything that you might put on that
billboard?
Danny Meyer: Can't we please have a charitable
assumption about one another?
I think I'd put that on there.
I feel like when we go into a conversation
with somebody or read about somebody and we
assume the worst as the starting point, it
doesn't usually end up very well.
On the other hand, when you assume the best
intentions, you just never know.
It's very possible that you hadn't communicated,
understood what someone really meant.
And I feel like going into any relationship
or experience with a charitable assumption
is such a helpful thing.
Tim Ferriss: Is that something that you've
had out of the box?
You mentioned the glass half full even before
you uncorked the bottle.
But in this particular context, going into
say, conversations, having charitable assumptions
as opposed to assuming the worst, is that
something you've cultivated?
Is that something that just seems to come
with your hardwiring?
Danny Meyer: I just think that's who I am.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, great.
Danny Meyer: I don't think it's something
I've ever thought consciously about, but I
do know that it's not just about being optimistic,
but it's about being hopeful.
There is a difference between hope and optimism.
I think that hope is an active act.
I think it's — so much of this gets back
to growing up.
My parents got divorced after 25 years, and
I'm watching all these conversations and there's
two truths to every single conversation.
And I think one of the gifts I got as a kid
was getting to cherry-pick the good stuff
from each of my parents and leave the bad.
Didn't make them bad people.
It's just like you pick and choose, but you
start from a standpoint, this person actually
means well, their intention is to do the right
thing.
And we're all flawed, we all make mistakes
constantly, but that's not a reason to vilify
us.
The other thing I'll just say is that you've
clearly gotten the sense I live my life within
the 40-yard lines.
I don't live my life on the five yard lines
where you can't hear people yelling at each
other from the five yard lines of a football
field.
And I know that we've gotten so tribal in
this country, so tribal with everything that
if you're not all the way on one side or the
other, you're wrong.
And that's just not how I look at life.
It just gives me great joy to find how can
we make progress together?
And it starts with assuming the best in people.
Tim Ferriss: Danny, we've covered a lot of
ground and we're honing in on nearly two hours
now or roughly two hours.
And as we wind to a close, is there anything
else that you would like to say or request?
Could be a request of my audience, could be
anything at all that maybe we didn't discuss
that you'd like to bring up.
Any closing comments, complaints you'd like
to lodge publicly?
Anything at all?
Danny Meyer: Go support your local restaurants
and your local butchers and your local fruit
growers, et cetera.
You cannot know how important for the economy
and also for just the emotional fabric of
a community restaurants are.
Restaurants provide a place for the community
to come together and do their social life,
to do their business life, to do their personal
life.
We saw what life looked like when we didn't
have restaurants during Covid, and it gets
to the human desire to connect with people.
People are so eager to be with people.
And so the more you can do to support people
who work in the food industry, that's my hope.
Tim Ferriss: I think that's a perfect place
to — and Danny, thank you so much for making
the time.
It's really nice to have a long-form conversation
with you.
And I appreciate you carving time out of your
schedule to do this.
So first and foremost, thank you very much.
I have tons of notes, many things to follow
up on, many things to think about, which is
always the sign.
Danny Meyer: I'm really grateful to you and
thank you for sharing me with your amazing
audience.
And I hope I'll get to see you in New York.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely.
I do love New York City.
I mean, there's no place like New York City.
Danny Meyer: Or at a Shake Shack near you.
By the way, at the Shake Shack in Austin,
we have a burger there that we only do in
Austin.
Tim Ferriss: No kidding.
All right, so I can find that on Lamar, on
the South Lamar location?
Danny Meyer: You can find it there.
And it's called the Lockhart Link.
So we get an amazing sausage from Lockhart,
Texas and put it right on top of a Shack Burger.
I wish we had those in New York, but only
in Austin.
Tim Ferriss: All right, that's on my to-do
list.
And for those who don't know, Lockhart, very
famous.
This is one of the meccas of delicious meat
here in central Texas.
So I will have to try the Lockhart Link.
And for people listening, they can find you
Danny on Twitter @DHMeyer.
Instagram also @DHMeyer.
We'll link to many, many other things that
we've discussed.
I recommend people check out Setting the Table,
your book.
They can find USHG at ushg.com, as well as
your team member description and so on.
And I will add links to everything we discussed
in the show notes for folks after the fact.
And you'll be able to find that as always
at tim.blog/podcast.
And until next time, be just a bit kinder
than you think is necessary to others and
to yourself.
Assume good intentions, make charitable assumptions
about the next person you're going to have
a conversation with.
And as always, thanks for tuning in.